- Les lecteurs étaient nombreux
vendredi matin à l'ouverture
des portes du 10e Salon du livre
des Premières Nations.
LOUIS-KARL PICARD-SIOUI, dir.,
Salon du livre Premières Nations
- Il y a vraiment un intérêt
de plus en plus prononcé,
de plus en plus manistste de la
part du grand public québécois.
- Au cours de la dernière
décennie, l'écriture autochtone
a grandement évolué.
- Il y a beaucp p plus
d'auteurs pratiquants,
c'est-à-dire pas juste des gens
qui publient un livre, et puis,
qui passent à autre chose,
mais vimiment des auteurs qui
ont des carrières, et surtout,
il y a une diversification
notable des styles, des genres.
On est rendus là.
Ça, on n'aurait pas vu ça
il y a cinq, six ans.
On peut avoir autant des trucs,
disons, policier ou d'enquête,
je devrais dire, que des
trucs un peu plus ténébreux,
des trucs très, très joyeux.
Donc au niveau des genres, des
ylylyles, il y a une explosion t
il y a en pour tous les goûts.
Et je suppose que c'est ça
qui fait aussi qu'il y a
un intérêt grandissant
parce que le grand public peut
y trouver son compte peu importe
ses intérêts personnels.
- Michel Jean, Josephine Bacon,
Natasha Kanapé Fontaine
et d'autres grands noms
de la littérature des
Premières Nations sont présents
ce week-end. La programmation
du Salon du livre est bien plus
qu'une succession de séance
de dédicaces.
- Pour moi, c'est véritablement
plus un festival. C'est-à-dire
qu'on trouve différentes faç
d'incarner la littérature
et c'est ça qui est
important pour
On est des facilitateurs.
Moi, c'est comme ça
que je vois le salon.
- Tables rondes, entretiens,exp;
les activités se multiplient
sous différentes formes,
toujours autour de la
littérature. Le Salon du livre
des Premières Nations
se poursuit jusqu'à dimanche.
Ici Tanya Beaumont,
Radio-Canada, Québec.